[Music]
thank you I'm Kimberly um while we are
locating my for slide presentation
excellent
that was a tymberlee nice way of
conveying the fact that I constantly
[ __ ] about canvas all the time and to
start with and to just say that this is
what I do it does support foreign
languages but only to a certain extent
what is that certain extent it does not
support it I'm sorry generally but I
know I've been listening to how amazing
that system is for an hour and a half
now also I do function with very few
hours of sleep so I will stick to my
notes to the best of my ability so in
the comment section and this is
significant it does not support the
foreign language so either answer your I
mean correct your students problems or
mistakes in English or find all sorts of
various ways of not using any
punctuation marks or many other things
that just does not it doesn't cut it so
this is our aim and attempt to an appeal
to the canvas gods to make it slightly
more a foreign language friendly but
with that everything I present here
today I should credit in addition to the
Hebrew program very specifically aura
care at my colleague who is a canvas
genius so whenever I am stuck with
something I always go to her and I what
I wanted to do is just take a step back
and and briefly and talk a little bit
about homework and why homework is so
significant in in foreign language
education in particular and I took
Kimberly's advice as I always do very
seriously
I had no visuals related to them except
for two to the presentation so I just
randomly added pictures of Israel
made by a very talented photographer his
name is Judy Corrine happens to be my
cousin
so Yael has a strong commitment to a
liberal arts education as we all know
and part of it is the foreign language
requirement that means that every
student who comes to Yale has to take a
foreign language it doesn't matter what
their level in a certain language is
they can choose to take a new language
they can decide to expand their
knowledge in an existing language but in
any event each and every one of them is
taking at least one course in a foreign
language Hebrew as many other languages
that have been that were presented here
today Arabic included in Korean of
course is what is called the less or
consider the less commonly taught
language that means that we don't unlike
the more commonly taught languages
Spanish for example I always blame them
for everything we do not have really
good sorry we do not have very good book
textbooks so we have to glean our
pedagogy and materials from different
sources and this is where canvas and is
very very effective there is one other
issue and this I will have to actually
look at it and this is the difficult
level of foreign languages in general
there is a division we should took it
with a grain of salt but generally
speaking Hebrew belongs to a category
four in level and language and that is
it was made by that division was made by
the Foreign Service Institute after US
Department of State and that means that
in order to achieve an advanced level
advanced meet in actual scale and it's
called RS in their scale a student needs
to have one 1100 hours contact hours in
the language now if we do it simple math
because this is all I am capable of
being from the humanities at Yale we
teach five hours a week for say 26 weeks
I mean if we exclude exams and things
like that but this is actually include
those hours so that's 130 hours a year
let's say that the student is highly
committed and they take 8 semesters of
the language we're still even less than
half of where we should be in order to
have them reach that level that means
that we really need to rely on homework
and on work done outside of classroom
and to that and I want to just show you
how we use in the Hebrew program we use
canvas and again I credit or eat for
this beautiful idea of dividing courses
in two weeks so students yes they do
have to count but only 2:13 and
therefore know when they are in which
week but once we press and they have all
the work that they need to do it's also
convenient for for me if I want to embed
and show certain clips in class I don't
have to go back to my email and you know
get it from there I just click and it's
there and and then every at the end of
every class and it's always in green
that's color I like and it's not as
intimidating as red they pressed and
they have lists of everything that they
need to do for homework no that's not
that why is it significant because here
as you can see they have six different
homework assignments and they need to
know where to get things from and and
when we have everything in one place
they just click and and get to where
they need to be so it functions very
much like the modules only it
incorporates many other sources yeah I'm
good
and in addition to sending them to
specific specific website
I also here send them to the specific
assignments that they need to respond to
and here I will end with just one minor
complaint and last one and because they
have to basically submit seven different
things for each class sometimes they
don't do them those things at once and
the problem is that I print after the
problem is that when they upload the
material they need to upload everything
together so if they have seven files for
example if we send them to do some
online activity and then I ask them to
do a screenshot of the activity so that
I know that they've done it and also
what was what went wrong what was good
etc they have to submit everything at
once because if they do it in two times
for example the first time gets erased
so we do need something we leave
something else to for them and prove to
take care of other than that being
working with canvas for two years I do
like it I don't tell him really that but
it is much more convenient and
straightforward once you get the hang of
it then classes v2 was and the team is
is highly professional and responsive to
the extent that they can so at least
they will hear you and complain about
things and say yes yes we're working on
it we promise to make it better thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]